I think it's like that with alligators in Florida.
Yeah.
When I was a kid,
they were an endangered species.
They would ask us to please not feed them marshmallows.
Cause I lived in Gainesville right by this place called Lake Alice Lake outside
alligators was fucking 11 years old.
I was living in an alligator.
This was crazy.
It was a goddamn dinosaur.
But there was a small population of them cause they had been whacked into
oblivion before and people were making suitcases out of them.
And then they made it illegal to hunt them and they made him a protected
species.
But then they fucked up.
They overprotected and those God damn super lizards are everywhere.
Fucking everywhere.
My mom belongs to a golf course down in Florida where she lives.
And there's this alligator's apparently like this fucking 14 foot alligator.
And uh,
the people were playing golf and it was a deer.
And everybody's on the,
everybody standing there going like,
it's a deer.
It's a deer.
Look at that beautiful fucking alligator comes out,
grabs it,
pulls it into the water,
does that spin move?
Takes it to the bottom.
Fucking done.
So everyone's talking about it,
what do we do about it?
So about three weeks later,
my mom is out on the course and her ball is right next to the lake where the
alligator is and she forgets and she goes over and her ball is right on the edge
and she's standing there and she was standing on some fucking like dead,
some dead grass.
And he gave out and she fell in the fucking lake up to her neck.
And then she remembered and she fucking started scrambling up the mud and
grabbing at the reeds to get out of there.
And her and the people that who she was with had left,
she was playing by herself for some reason and she fucking got out of there and
got in the cart and,
and then she just started laughing.
Oh my God.
You believe that shit.
My little mother,
my little five foot two mother
would have been a tasty meal and so quick.
Yeah.
Better than a dear old lady.
Nice.
Soft.
All Lady.
Way more tender.
Yeah.
Corn Fed.
My mom's corn fed.
I never told you that.
Yeah.
I thought she was organic now.
Now we let her free range.
Sometimes
there's a great story about a car chase.
The cops were chasing this too with Solon car and a guy jumps off a bridge into
the water and immediately gets eaten by alligators.
Wow.
He's like a little overpass over river,
which is hops out of the fucking car,
jumps into the river and smash.
He lands right in front of an alligator.
No Sheldon Jackson in front of the cops.
Wow.
What do you do of your cop?
Do you shoot it?
The alligator?
Do you try to kill the alligator was killing the guy.
Good point.
I mean,
that's a reckless thing to be doing when there's a lot of thrashing around.
You're just going to empty your clip,
pat.
Pat,
you know,
I mean,
how much distance is there between the bridge,
the water,
right?
What can the cop do?
Well,
you know the guy's going to die.
So I think it's a,
I think it's a safe bet to take some shots anyway.
I think it's a not safe bet to take some shots because if you're a cop,
what have you hit the guy and they said,
oh,
you shot and trying to cover up by literally a fucking alligators.
Eat them.
It's true.
You got to let the alligator eat them.
Now you got to save your job here about the guy who was the guy flying a plane
from Florida to Cuba or,
or Cuba to Florida,
and the plain fucking went down and he survived the crash and then got eaten by
sharks.
That's so fun.
Is that that 20 minute period where you're floating in the water,
but you're thankful and you're almost giddy?
I did it.
I fucking survived.
Oh my God.
Yeah.
Bad Day.
Well,
you know that story about the World War II boat that sank in,
the guys were floating around at sea for several days and most of them got eaten
by sharks.
Oh,
that's the store that they talk about in the beginning of jaws.
Yeah.
I remember where the captain,
the captain at the fucking scars and he starts talking about his,
uh,
his time on the boat.
Yeah.
Do you remember that scenery?
Scheider no,
not Roy Scheider.
The guy was talking to Roy Scheider.
Okay.
Who's that guy?
What's that guy's name again?
Old Time Act.
And the guy was fucking amazing.
Spool up jaws to quit.
Richard Dreyfus.
No,
no,
no.
Richard drivers was a scientist.
Roy Scheider was the sheriff.
Richard Dreyfus was the scientist.
And then there's,
uh,
an older gentleman.
Oh yeah.
Right.
He steals that fucking fuck.
Yeah.
Heals up movie.
Where is he?
Right here.
He steals that fucking movie.
He steals how fucking movie you believe him?
Wait,
so what was the opening scene?
Not the opening scene,
but he describes what it was like.
No,
that's a different shark attack typed in World War II.
All the naval ship.
Yeah,
that's it.
That's it.
I'm sorry.
I was thinking once the worst shark attack in history.
I was thinking it was that story about New Jersey where the bull sharks killed
people.
Scroll back up so I can see what it says here.
1945 US naval ship was sunk by a Japanese summering.
The ship's sinking was just the beginning of the sailors nightmare.
Yeah,
that's the boat.
That's the story.
How many people died?
Hello?
Shit load.
Let's see.
300 people died of the 1,196 men aboard 900 made it into the water alive there
ordeal.
So that's,
that's how many survived the crash.
So there's 900 of them that are alive now.
How many of them make it to the end?
Out of 900 scroll,
Scroll,
Scroll.
Let's grow it.
Yeah,
this is,
they're just giving you the full line of the story that I'm giving you.
Just the actual facts.
317 remained.
So,
so almost 600 people got to eat
estimates of the number who die from shark attacks range from a few dozen to
almost 150
so the other people die from other things.
Oh,
heat stroke being in the water could be.
And so I bet when those guys died,
then the sharks ate them and it got even worse.
Fuck man.
Wow,
that's fucking crazy.
Just imagine 150 people eaten by sharks.
The amount of blood in the water,
fucking Christ,
you know,
but when you around any kind of thing that can eat you and kill you,
it puts it all into perspective that you're not,
you're not around that enough.
And it's not,
it's not like you should be around it all the time,
but you should know it's a real thing.
And when you were around it,
you go like,
oh,
oh sharks just,
we'll just eat.
You owe a bear will just eat you.
Oh,
a mountain lion will just eat you.
Oh.
Like these people that got killed this year was a,
or 2018 at least was very rare.
And that two people were documented,
killed by mountain lions in the Pacific northwest.
One guy in Portland outside of Portland and one guy outside of Seattle.
It's pretty rare that mountain lions do that.
But Oh,
not lines will just eat you.
Oh,
that can happen too.
Like we think we're so safe,
Dave.
And I think it,
I think you're right.
It will keep you in the moment.
I think we should release like grizzly in cities just because like you might be
worried about,
oh,
am I the fucking stock market's down,
or I think my wife's cheating,
and you're right back in.
Yeah,
you're in the moment.
But then you going to have to allow people to be armed to protect themselves.
Guys going to have open carry,
fucking ar slung around their shoulders looking out for bears everywhere.
Taking your kid to school,
you'd better bring the rifle.